c'est l'époque du cuir du latex des
toilettes du Grand Rex
on passe à notre ttu de la semaine alors
Christophe tu étais où on ne voit plus
aux soirées
alors flashback après avoir quitté
Faites entrer l'accusé de votre plein
gré ce qui vous a pas empêché de
critiquer votre remplaçante je le
regrette
[Rires]
ça c'est ça
alors après avoir quitté Faites entrer
l'accusé de votre plein gré oui ce qui
nous a pas empêché de critiquer votre
remplaçant
[Musique]
après avoir quitté le trésor de France 2
peu de temps avant le direct à cause
d'un article dans Libération
je pète les plombs après avoir
quitté le plateau de On n'est pas couché
suite à une critique d'Audrey Pulvar
[Musique]
après avoir quitté la rédaction de RTL
suite à une dispute avec votre assistant
après avoir quitté le plateau de Thierry
c'est vrai sérieusement après tout ça
vous êtes un petit peu sorti des des
radars il y a eu un passage à vide
médiatique je raccompagne je le
reconnais humblement je suis passé en
deuxième division mais je continue à
jouer et là après tout ça Christophe
vous avez opéré une reconversion
étonnante dans le cirque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est le cirque par mer Christophe
on a pressé des siens
alors en fait non vous étiez pas du tout
au cirque Pinder vous êtes reconverti
dans la chanson s'il n'est pas du tout
alors ça c'est une interprétation
abusive j'ai choisi un peu d'avoir un
peu de liberté par rapport à l'idée que
les gens se font de une carrière
organisée etc donc je me donne les
moyens de cette liberté ça a été la
chanson mais là dans les deux trois ans
qui viennent je me concentre à nouveau
sur ma carrière professionnelle parce
que sinon sinon je vais finir avant des
tomates quoi non j'en ai bien conscience
voilà mais ça ne veut pas dire pas plus
tard qu'hier après-midi j'ai répété près
de 4 heures avec avec mon pianiste et je
continue de chanter
ça c'est ce qu'a dit le pianiste
bon en fait non sérieusement à l'époque
je tiens un peu dépressif c'est vrai oui
c'était dû un médicament qui s'appelle
le Lyrica le médicament que vous prenez
contre votre mal au dos c'est l'époque
du cuir du latex des toilettes du Grand
Rex oh dis donc fais pas ta bagel toi
non mais je rêve
je me languis
elle latex
et les toilettes du grand
[Musique]
c'est la nuit à fond la toile
si loin si près des étoiles
perdu mon temps
[Musique]
j'assume
non mais vous avez déclaré si c'était à
refaire je le referai pas donc c'est oui
je leur ferai pas comme je l'ai fait là
j'étais à l'époque très accompagné par
mon employeur que j'étais en playlist
sur RTL etc donc et en même temps
finalement cette aventure c'est mal
terminée pour eux pour moi en même temps
donc c'est bon c'était mal géré
après tout Mozart à jamais vendu indice
de son voyage
donc voilà donc après votre départ de
RTL ça a été un petit peu la traversée
du désert et a eu la web tv de Yahoo la
chaîne 23 23 c'est le nombre de gens qui
regardent
jamais vu cette chaîne de ma vie écoute
quand on est comme moi c'est gourmandé
des gens de ce qu'ils ont dans les
tripes de moi je m'ennuie nulle part
après c'est toujours un peu frustrant
personne te regarde bon et bien il y a
eu 13e Rue beaucoup plus regardé vous
avez fait Hondelatte par en live
[Musique]
non
Alpha Jet de la Patrouille de France
j'ai fait des tas de trucs en Afrique du
Sud en Afrique du Sud
et là Christophe vous revenez dans la
lumière sur BFM c'est vrai qu'ils nous
ont fait signer une clause de non
démission à moins de deux heures du
journal
en fait je fais deux tranches d'infos
20h 21h l'exercice classique du journal
sincèrement je pensais ne jamais refaire
ma vie ne vous faites bien et 22 minutes
qui est assez proche de ce que je
faisais déjà à la radio qui est un talk
chaude info
vous étiez dingue de fait entrer
l'accusé je crois que pour vous c'était
moi je préférais quand c'était
Christophe
ah là là il ferme la baie vitrée
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu